qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire ce soir
je peux vous dire que on va s'écrire ces
influenceurs et merci d'avoir dénoncé
leur arnaque et le combat continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où ça sur les réseaux sociaux et réseaux
sociaux on sait que c'est le seul ou
principal vecteur de culture d'intérêt
notamment de la jeunesse la société
shona events elle a été mise en cause en
l'occurrence puisque la société c'est la
société qui dirigeait pas Magali Berda
et Magali Baba se présente comme le
principal agent d'influenceuse par
exemple elle-même elle a fait de la
vente de de formation
pouvant être financés par le compte de
professionnels de formation donc tant
elle-même que cette influenceurs ont été
mis en cause pourquoi parce que derrière
des produits qu'elle a fait qu'elle a
vendu dont elle a fait la promotion il y
avait de l'abus donc il y a eu les
phénomènes quand même c'est extrêmement
grave la chirurgie esthétique on a vendu
à des gamines des prestations de
chirurgie esthétique ça a été n'importe
quoi là on parle quand même de santé
publique donc entre la santé publique
d'un côté et des gens qui se sont
truffés qui n'osent pas porter plainte
parce que dénoncer un influenceur c'est
prendre le risque de se voir flasher sur
un réseau social par quelqu'un qui
parfois comme vous peut-être des
centaines de milliers de followers donc
les gens ont peur personne ne dit rien
donc là moi je dis heureusement que
c'est trouvé Booba qui franchement n'est
pas très modéré par la peur qui a vu ce
truc qu'il l'a pris en main qui l'a pris
en grippe on aura des et qui a décidé de
le dénoncer ça va mon Booba
fais
gaffe fais gaffe fais gaffe quand même
comment ça va
ça va
je t'entends mal je t'entends on
t'entend hyper mal qu'est-ce que tu peux
nous dire ce soir
je peux vous dire que on va se faire ces
influenceurs et merci d'avoir dénoncé
l'Internet et le combat continue
[Musique]
parmi les personnes qui buzz aujourd'hui
on parle d'Amandine Pélissard candidate
de la téléréalité famille nombreuse la
vie en XXL et si cette mère de 8 enfants
est au cœur de l'actualité c'est pour
l'interview qu'elle a accordé à Jordan
Deluxe où elle se livre sur sa vie
privée
c'est lorsque la jeune femme a déclaré
avoir volé de la nourriture pour ses
enfants lorsqu'elle avait des problèmes
financiers quand on transgresse la loi
on transgresse les règles on a tous
malheureusement une raison de le faire
Amandine a été placé en garde à vue et
risque aujourd'hui six mois de prison
ferme 2016 j'ai malheureusement
volé de la nourriture dans un
supermarché en Franche-Comté où je
vivais à l'époque pour mes enfants
puisque j'étais dans une dans une époque
où la vie était très compliqué pour moi
et pour ma famille mon mari venait de
perdre ton travail en fait l'entreprise
où le travail depuis 10 ans a fermé moi
j'étais en arrêt pathologique parce que
j'étais enceinte avec une menace
d'accouchement prématuré j'ai d'ailleurs
fait une fausse couche j'ai fait une
fausse couche entre donc mon cinquième
et mon sixième en fait donc le problème
c'est que on s'est retrouvé du jour au
lendemain avec plus rien malheureusement
il y a des délais incompressibles quand
on se retrouve
ou licencier ou en arrêt maladie il y a
des délais et de carence et des délais
administratifs qui ne sont pas
malheureusement
très très pertinent dans le sens où on
se retrouve foncièrement plusieurs
semaines sans rien donc vous avez volé
de la nourriture à l'époque c'était où
c'était quoi c'était en France vous avez
fait un supermarché en fait j'avais un
caddie de course à roulettes comme plein
en nous et je le remplissais et en fait
je passais au caisses express et je
sortais que très peu de choses
et à quoi vous êtes fait attraper je me
suis fait attraper au bout de quelques
fois
et quand vous aujourd'hui la justice
vous rattrape sur cette et le problème
c'est que la justice est très longue
donc là l'effet remonte à fin 2016 le
jugement a eu lieu fin 2017 moi j'étais
en train d'accoucher à ce moment là ce
que je n'ai pas trop
détaillé chez Jordan le problème c'est
qu'en fait je n'ai pas été avisé
du jugement parce qu'en fait un huissier
de justice est venu sonner chez moi un
jour sans doute et en fait j'étais jugé
par défaut et donc aujourd'hui vous
risquez quoi alors donc j'ai pris six
mois à faire parce que j'étais que j'ai
une première fois donc par défaut j'ai
fait opposition à ce jugement
une fois hein
je pense que je n'étais pas là et je
n'ai pas été récupéré ma condamnation
enfin mon avis voilà ma convocation chez
lui c'est de justice et je pense que ça
ça a joué on m'a défaveur mais l'absence
effectivement c'était notifié d'ailleurs
le fait que vous n'étiez pas à
l'audience à jouer contre vous parce
qu'on a estimé que vous vous dérobiez et
donc du coup la peine a été maximale
alors on dirait que je n'ai pas eu la
absolument vous êtes responsable c'était
votre faute entre guillemets donc on
appelle même si à six mois ferme c'est
vrai que ce sera aménagé mais ça fait
frémir 6 mois ferme pour avoir nourri
ses enfants en France
il y avait moins de 200 euros de
nourriture
il y a un amalgame qui a été créé sur
les réseaux sociaux
je pense volontairement aujourd'hui
depuis le mois de mai donc moi si je
suis venue ici ce soir sur ce plateau je
vais vous le dire très clairement c'est
uniquement par rapport à mes enfants par
rapport à ma famille parce que demain
c'est la rentrée des classes et que j'ai
pas envie que ma famille que mes enfants
rentrent dans la cour de récréation avec
la boule au ventre comme elle l'ont
depuis trois mois et demi
parce qu'il s'est dit des choses sur ce
plateau lundi
qui sont pour moi
impardonnables c'est inacceptable
d'avoir aucune thé ce qui s'est passé
dans ma vie depuis trois mois et demi on
est quand même une famille ici vous me
l'avez déjà plusieurs reprises et j'ai
entendu toutes les discours que vous
avez tenus sur le silence
ne vous a pas attaqué à nominés
c'est s'il y a des arnaques ou pas je
vais vous dire la guéguerre Booba Magali
Berda bien sûr ça nous fait non mais non
mais ça fait de la peine à tout le monde
ça fait de la peine à tout le monde ça
gêne tout le monde ça fait de la peine à
tout le monde on est très triste pour
votre famille mais on est très compliqué
si vous aviez votre enfant qui vous
demandez est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est toi sur une vidéo pornographique
qu'on lui envoie par milliers est-ce que
recevoir aujourd'hui 60
on a une baisse de chiffre d'affaires
qui est conséquente aussi depuis un an
et demi deux ans parce qu'on a refusé
énormément de sites on refuse de plus en
plus de sites on a créé un service
juridique on a mis plein de choses en
place et ça ça date de il y a deux ans
maintenant pour que ce soit propre si
vous voulez que le milieu de l'influence
soit propre et je l'ai déjà dit donc
c'est pour ça que c'est pas que je ne
veux pas m'en justifier parce que je
trouve que je n'ai pas mon justifié je
l'ai déjà fait mais je vais le redire si
ça vous intéresse il faut qu'il y ait
des règles qui soient mis en place j'ai
contacté plusieurs
personnes des autorités compétentes
l'année dernière pour leur demander des
rendez-vous pour parler avec eux pour
discuter pour leur proposer des choses
parce que je suis sur le terrain depuis
2016 et que j'estime que voilà et je
j'attends j'attends les rendez-vous et
on a arrêté de parler de CPF depuis le
mois de février c'est-à-dire que nous
nos influenceurs on a pu le faire on le
fait plus dans les briefs on demande à
ce que ce soit plus en argument parce
que malheureusement il y a des gens
malhonnêtes qui passent des accords avec
des gens et tout et nous on veut pas
rentrer là-dedans je ne peux pas tolérer
un harcèlement en meute d'accord
c'est pas possible oui mais l'affaire a
commencé comme ça c'est que j'ai juste
que chronologiquement
mettre les choses à leur place et c'est
pour ça que je suis venu parce que je
veux que les gens qui vous regardent
l'entendre parce que lundi ils n'ont pas
attendre ils l'ont pas entendu Booba
jusqu'à la mort mais moi en fait je suis
pas là pour faire un un combat de boxe
en fait si je suis là pour vivre
travailler j'ai on a des employés qui
qui se lèvent le matin qui sont
respectables et il faut les respecter
aussi
[Musique]
peut-on porter n'importe quelle tenue à
l'école depuis de nombreuses années la
question fait débats dernièrement une
lycéenne déclare avoir été exclue de son
école c'est pour avoir porté cette tenue
voici ma tenue appropriée qui m'a valu
une exclusion et un avertissement car
selon ma prof et l'administration de mon
école c'est provocateur cette nouvelle
polémique intervient alors que certains
adolescents aimeraient bien s'habiller
comme ils le souhaitent mais cette tenue
elle a rien de choquant
arrêtez on a tous été au lycée comme ça
TOI
me contacter sur Instagram on a tous été
au lycée on a tous été à la fac on a
tous vu des tenues comme ça je pense pas
que les filles
moi ce que j'aime pas dans son message
c'est le mot provocateur ça veut dire
quoi sert qu'en fait il y a des hommes
qui ont des réactions déplacées c'est de
sa faute je trouve que c'est
profondément injuste et je pense que
blague à part elle est victime une sorte
de délit de sale gueule inversé parce
que c'est une belle fille et qu'en fait
les gens qui ont pris cette décision
sont des gens frustrés et gris qui eux
sont peut-être pas beaux comme elle elle
est belle et ont décidé de la
sanctionner pour ça et franchement il y
a pas de quoi virer quelqu'un pour une
tenue comme ça
pas la fille elle est clairement en
soutif là elle a elle a une tenue
d'Instagram et je pense que il se
rendent plus compte de ce qui est la vie
réelle et la vie virtuelle ils sont en
train de tout mélanger et tu vas pas
dans ta vie virtuelle au lycée ou à
l'école c'est impossible c'est pas
quelque chose de normal il y a pas
d'hypersexualisation elle est bien dans
sa tenue elle est bien dans sa vie et on
va la briser en l'avion on va la briser
elle a froid c'est toi qui nous les
brise oui
on va briser sa vie là le prénom d'une
morale
cette fille est déjà brisée en allant à
l'école comme ça
depuis le début de l'émission regarde la
photo allez on soutien-gorge avec un
truc ouvert on voit son horrible c'est
c'est descend pour les à l'école ça
c'est que tout ça normal c'est c'est
normal elle est couvert elle est
couverte d'où là elle est à poil et
aller à poil elle est à poil à
l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
il y a des codes sociaux c'est pas
Pattaya c'est pas un doute tu vois c'est
pas une règle Ibiza donc je pense que
cette tenue est totalement inappropriée
je trouve qu'elle a eu raison d'être
enfin le chef d'établissement a eu
raison de la dégager et la même manière
alors à ce moment-là le chef le prof il
va arriver en paréo et on tombe et on
dira bah ouais finalement tout ça c'est
cool tout est possible et puis on va
faire l'amour dans la cour de récré
ouais ben pourquoi pas après tout
non mais qu'on s'étonne pas après que
les gens fuient l'école publique et
mettent leurs enfants dans les écoles
privées où il y a des uniformes et les
gens sont tous habillés pareil mais j'ai
qu'une question tu laisses ta fille elle
est à l'école comme ça le truc mais je
discute avec elle on peut discuter et
c'est elle qui choisira en dernier
ressorts tout le temps c'est l'éducation
arrêtez de faire en sorte que les gamins
décident de tout ce qu'on peut créer un
site qu'on y apprend à l'école de quand
on y va à quelle heure quand ça les
arrange pas répond à la question
elle te dit papa je me casse en
sous-titre
avec elle je réponds à vous tiens alors
allez-y honnêtement à son âge là
aujourd'hui sans doute pas mais après je
discute avec elle s'il a envie de se
maquiller c'est l'envie de sa mère
tu fais la langue de bois là tu la
laisses partir ou pas dis pas de bêtises
sa mère non moi je serai plus évident si
elle me dit papa je veux vraiment cette
tenue pour aujourd'hui j'accepterai ben
voilà c'est ce voilà donc il l'a dit
excuse-moi mais tu es complètement à
côté c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit fait
tout tous les soirs donc
[Rires]
tu te reprends on est en direct à chaque
fois tu dis des bêtises qui sont énormes
on est en train de défendre l'éducation
défendre certaines valeurs parce que
justement si tu veux que cette gamine
soit un jour heureux dans la vie il faut
qu'elle a un cadre des valeurs le rôle
des parents c'est d'éduquer c'est pas de
pas dire aux enfants fais ce que tu es
ma chérie fais ce que tu veux quand tu
veux
un enfant dans le mur vous caricaturez
pas je t'écoute vous incarnez les forces
de la réaction moi j'essaye d'être dans
le force du progrès de comprendre les
jeunes garçons
c'est embêtant comme d'habitude parce
que vous avez pas d'arguments donc c'est
un problème pour moi j'ai rien en face
de moi
de toute façon
avec mon petit banderole comme ça
aux questions
depuis que le rappeur dénonce les
pratiques commerciales des influenceurs
de camps ensemble désormais s'opposer il
y a d'un côté ceux qui dénonce ce
système mais les produits que ces
célébrités d'Internet nous vendent sur
les réseaux sociaux on est complètement
gonflé je ne conseille absolument pas ce
produit là nous avons pris pour des
pigeons se trouvent les influenceurs
pour en pratique n'ont rien d'illégal
n'écoutez pas tout ce que vous voyez sur
les réseaux sociaux la personne arnaquer
personne vous inquiétez pas est-ce que
c'est vrai que il y a des produits qui
valent 10 balles qui sont vendus 50
balles par exemple mais alors évidemment
tu as eu des produits mais ça a été sur
Aliexpress je connais pas dire non quand
même je suis pas fou pour te dire non il
y a des produits qui se vendent 10
balles apparemment que d'autres vent de
50 balles maintenant nous on est pas
entre guillemets
on sait moi en tout cas moi je parle
pour moi je me lève pas le matin en
disant tiens je vais voler la France je
peux venir je vais prendre un truc sur
Allier express et je vais le vendre 50
euros alors qu'il m'a coûté 5 €, c'est
pas mon but d'accord on a une on a des
agences
et en vrai on travaille main dans la
main donc je remets pas tout sur les
agents c'est pas vrai eux ils viennent
ils nous propose quelque chose tu veux
le faire ou tuer même pas ce que c'est
en fait
ce que c'est mais c'est tout dépend les
agences j'ai vu d'un côté l'avocat de
Booba qui vient poser les choses en
termes juridique et expliquer quels sont
les problèmes qui se posent j'ai vu de
l'autre une jeune femme une influenceuse
qui finalement
qui effectivement tout à fait et qui
vient t'expliquer qu'elle a créé un
métier de toutes pièces dont elle
ignorait tout de celui-ci puisque
forcément il n'existait pas et que elle
a peut-être fait des erreurs mais c'est
une bonne fois ben oui mais si ces
erreurs elles consistent dans des
pratiques commerciales trompeuses ou nos
escroquerie s'appelle pas des erreurs
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit après ça elle a
dit que s'il y avait eu des erreurs et
qu'il fallait
sur terre quand même en fait là où ça me
fait marrer votre plateau c'est que
quand moi je balance des trucs tout le
monde est contre moi pas moi quand il
est venu il a dit la même chose que moi
et tout le monde
il y a 2 minutes vous parliez oui vous
voulez qu'on fasse main dans la main et
tout ça pas du tout
ensemble on sait pas
je t'aime moi non plus exactement c'est
rien d'autre en fait on est là pour
réguler les pratiques rien d'autre
excusez-moi d'objectiver le débat
abandonné
c'est important qu'on ne fasse ensemble
c'est ce que vous avez dit oui oui vous
rappelez ça c'est bon ça va ok d'accord
vous venez ici pour autant vous tapez
sur nous en disant c'est des idiots tu
es bête des toute la journée
comment vous voulez qu'on fasse un
panier vous sentirez
parler 20 minutes laisse-le parler ok
merci donc comment on fait si nous on
veut venir vers vous mais toute la
journée on sent insulté comment on fait
pour vous ouvrir les portes et se dire
qu'on va faire quelque chose ensemble
dites-moi
j'étais insulté parce que vous le faites
attention je termine c'est que vous moi
je veux dire si vous intéresse pas que
je réponde si vous êtes la victime
permanente hier soir hier soir méga
libertin était la victime de Booba mais
si vous êtes une victime permanente pour
l'instant les vrais victimes ce sont
celles vous en savez rien
je vais vous ramener un nez rouge
pour se venger de son ex son ex qui est
kim Kardashian Kanye West le frère de
sushi euh révèle ses problèmes
intestinaux sur Instagram c'est la
guerre entre Kim et Kenny il a déclaré
sur Instagram kimala diarrhée très
souvent genre beaucoup plus que ce que
devrait avoir une personne normale le
gars ne devrait vraiment pas être fier
parce que quelqu'un qui fait autant aux
toilettes à ce point-là c'est quelqu'un
qui n'est pas heureux et qui est stressé
par la vie donc je pense qu'elle est
bien contente d'être séparée de ce mec
là parce qu'il veut vraiment la stresser
en fait c'était un peu un ouf à mon avis
là son transit va mieux il y a un
rapport entre la diarrhée et le bonheur
ne dit-on pas j'en chie avec toi
c'est une énorme star il est
milliardaire on pourrait croire qu'il
est déconnecté des réalités et là il
montre que il a le seum comme tout le
monde quand il se fait larguer par son
ex on se rend sympa franchement j'aime
bien mais ça le rend pas du tout sympa
c'est dégueulasse quelle est la diarrhée
ou pas ça nous regarde pas en fait c'est
sa vie privée je trouve que c'est ça en
commun
c'est dégueulasse
on sait que on sait que comme Kelly a
dit c'est vrai que quand on est en
couple quand on va beaucoup aux
toilettes c'est que on est stressé je
sais que Fatou nous regarde des
toilettes
on pense à toi voilà et on t'aime voilà
il voudrait que leur fille Norse aille
dans son académie dans son école
la maman ne veut pas il s'en prend à la
mer
et donc leur nom de famille c'est ouest
c'est une boussole
les gars c'est quoi cette cadavre c'est
le jeu de mots
ils ont fait ça
et comme la maman veut pas qu'elle
change d'école du coup il tape sur toute
la famille je trouve ça dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]